well it wouldn't be right for me to  comment on matters to do with the Royal  Palace although as as we've all seen  they've acknowledged what's happened and  made an apology for it  how did you feel when you heard this  story are those sentiments that you have  experienced in your life at all so I  mean I I've as I've talked about in the  past I have experienced racism in my  life but what I'm pleased to say is some  of the things that I experienced when I  was a kid and a young person I don't  think would happen today because our  country's made incredible progress in  tackling racism but the job is never  done and that's why whenever we see it  we must confront it and it's right that  we continually learn the lessons and  move to a better future